it's a bizarre first night of the
democratic national convention from john
kasich
oh no god no not john kasich to bernie
sanders to michelle obama and joe biden
is
as always an afterthought i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com well you may
have noticed that things are pretty
crazy
out there a lot of uncertainty out there
and that is one reason that the price of
gold
has been skyrocketing for quite a while
here some of us have been telling you
for literally years that you might want
to diversify at least a little bit
into precious metals and that the people
who should be using to do exactly that
are the folks over at birch gold that
was way back when gold was 1300
an ounce and just look right now gold is
at a new all-time high well that's
because gold and silver thrive
on uncertainty massive unemployment
resurgence and covid19
an election around the corner lots of
uncertainty well i'm telling you again
if you haven't reached out to birch gold
to diversify at least part of your iowa
ira or 401k into a precious metals ira
or just purchase
physical gold or silver from them go
ahead and do it today text ben 247
4747 get a free information kit on
protecting your savings
with gold then i have at least some of
my savings in gold and you should too
birch gold they've got an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five star reviews talk to them
have them help you safeguard your
investments they're extremely
knowledgeable they want to help you
preserve your savings ask all your
questions when you feel comfortable
talk to them about investing text ben
247 4747
when you open an ira and precious metals
before august 30th you will be the first
to get a signed copy of my brand new
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps
for free again tech spend 247 47
47 to get started okay so it was a very
very weird
first night of the democratic national
convention weird because
we're in the middle of a pandemic and so
basically it was a really bad zoom
session
like a really bad zoom session it lasted
for hours and hours and hours
it had extraordinarily bizarre moments
and as always joe biden was a complete
afterthought because biden is an
afterthought in this campaign the only
reason that joe biden is even the
nominee for the democrats
is because they literally looked at
every single other person and they went
okay we'll take the dead guy
that was pretty much how they came up
with joe biden as the nominee right they
even looked at bernie sanders to the
extent that we thought he was going to
be the nominee and then democrats were
like wait a second we can't nominate
a geriatric communist that seems like a
bad idea so instead they nominated the
corpse in the corner well if you watched
the first night of the dnc
joe biden it sounded like a eulogy for
joe biden frankly
it sounded like everybody had sort of
messages they wanted to get off their
chest about the state of america
and all these messages conflicted some
of them were were radical and some of
them were
were not radical at all some of them
were we're going to unite america and
some of them were
america's garbage i mean it was all over
the place but there was one common theme
president trump is super evil
and joe biden is literally not even here
right no one cares about joe biden
joey is completely irrelevant to these
proceedings kamala harris is so
irrelevant to the proceedings that when
michelle obama gave her speech
she recorded it like a week ago before
kamala harris had even been nominated
as the vp for joe biden and she couldn't
be bothered to
re-record it so that you could give some
sort of shout out to kamala harris which
shows you how much
michelle obama cares about kamala harris
being the vp but
the the real message of this thing was
twofold one
joe biden is a complete non-entity and
this entire election is about trump for
the democrats they don't care about joe
biden
and why should they i mean the guy's
lost 1 000 presidential elections before
the only reason he's even relevant is
because barack obama plucked him from
relative obscurity and made him vp that
is the only reason anyone cares about
joe biden
and now the only reason anyone cares
about joe biden is as an empty vessel
repository for all anti-trump sentiment
that's all he is
okay that is that it's the entirety
somebody who's not completely
off-putting who seems sort of empathetic
this is one of their big messages last
night
and who is not really anything right
he's just sort of
he's there he's just there he's sitting
in the corner
he's like the uh he's just this bizarre
kind of
mannequin that they've got standing in
the corner giving weird smiles to people
and smelling women's hair like that
that's that's all joe biden is that was
message number one it was all about how
trump sucks and it has nothing to do
with joe biden message number two and
became very clear that this was the case
last night
is that the democratic bench is just
empty absolutely empty so apparently the
new democratic formula for generating
popular politicians
is elected democratic president and then
make the president's wife
the next big thing this is the second
straight time democrats have done this
right now republicans don't do this
republicans didn't have laura bush
speaking at like the 2008 convention on
behalf of john mccain because
republicans generally don't really
assume
that the first lady is an elected
position in american government
that is deserving of the high sort of
honor of speaking at a convention it's a
non-political position right the first
lady of the united
that would be a st position that is a
person who's along for the ride
and that is why when bill clinton in
1992 suggested hillary would be
co-president everybody was like hold up
a second we didn't nominate that lady
we nominated you right we elected you
nobody elected hillary clinton
but democrats have this habit of
elevating the first ladies to very
political positions they've done the
same thing
with michelle obama and michelle is
definitely a smart lady
right she's been able to morph her own
image over time from extraordinarily
radical and off-putting
to everybody's aunt and now she's kind
of
injecting the politics back in the
partisan politics back in
you have to recognize the game that was
played in 2008 this was a lady who was
accused
of saying incredibly that to barack
obama all this for for a flag right i
mean
there's tape of her doing that it's
unclear what she's saying but people
have read her lips or they've tried to
this is the same lady who once said
openly that the first time she was proud
of her country and her adult life is
when her husband was nominated for the
presidency
and she's very very radical in terms of
her own sort of political viewpoints on
the united states she's very much in
line with this sort of 1619 project
idea that the united states was rooted
in evil and then she morphed into
well she's the nice lady who makes like
vegetable gardens right over at the
white house and is very unifying and is
a good mom and all of this no she was
always a good mom
but but that was the part of the
personality that they decided to focus
in on and then she wrote this very
popular book becoming
all about her american journey and now
she's morphing back into politics they
closed last night with michelle obama
who's never been elected to an office
at all right who is who is not a
relevant political figure
at all who herself has said that she
doesn't want to be seen as a relevant
political figure and yet there she was
closing out the night so how how shallow
is the democratic bench
their next big thing is the wife of the
last big thing right that that's how
shallow the bench is
so those were the two messages last
night is that democrats looked at
michelle and they said we wish that we
had nominated you
and joe biden is sitting off to the side
being a corpse
and that's good enough for them we're
going to jump into the actual
the the actual weirdness of the
convention in just one second because it
was
very odd and we're going to get to the
the true message of the convention which
actually happened before the convention
and then we'll get to or at least the
primetime convention then we'll get to
what happened in prime time which was
the stuff that people watch but not that
many i think the numbers on this thing
are really gonna be
pretty pretty awful we'll get to that in
just a moment first
let's talk about your sleep quality so i
will admit to you that i have a little
baby and she's the cutest thing in the
world and she also keeps us up all hours
of the night she was up at two last
night she was up at five last night
she will not sleep through the night so
those moments between
her feedings those are moments when i
definitely treasure my helix sleep
mattress helix sleep has made a mattress
that is just for me
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
whether you're a side sleeper or a hot
sleeper whether you like a plusher from
bed with helix there's no more confusion
and no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by gq and
wired magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on just go
to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you absolutely will
because it's made for you how could you
not love it helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders just for our
listeners right now get up to 200 bucks
off at helixsleep.com that is
helixsleep.com
again helix loop.com for up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders you're gonna
love it because it's made just for you
helixsleep.com
okay so before the primetime dnc
is when you actually got a solid window
onto what the dnc
actually is so in prime time is where
you show your best stuff
right basically the the prime time dnc
is the dating photo and all the stuff
that happens earlier in the day at the
dnc is the reality
right the dating photo everybody looks
like alyssa milano circa
1992 right and then in reality everybody
sorta looks like rosie o'donnell circa
1992. right that's that that's the way
that the that this works in terms of how
you present your party to the to the
general public there's the stuff that
you want
heavily publicized and then there's the
stuff okay so the stuff that's
that's all the stuff that happens before
prime time and there's a lot of stuff
happening
before prime time and it was replete
with some
rather telling moments and i think that
this is going to be wildly underplayed
by the media because of course they only
want to magnify the stuff that makes the
democrats look good
so we begin with the dnc chair
announcing full out before the prime
time
of the dnc he was on with the washington
post he announced that bernie sanders
was basically one of the driving forces
behind the democratic platform now this
is something
bernie himself said last night but it
was at war with what john kasich was
saying
which was the democrats are actually a
moderate party here was tom perez
letting the letting the beans out and
spilling the beans
about how bernie sanders really did
shape the dnc platform
the platform is a bold uh document it's
both
inspirational and aspirational the
input from senator sanders and others
was invaluable to putting that together
the vice president
and senator sanders convened a series of
policy groups on
critical issues okay so it was bernie
sanders who's the driving force
okay then you got to the actual
pre-prime time dnc
and this was replete with strange
moments so one of the pastors who gave a
prayer
at the at the pre-prime time dnc
and you can see how they uh have put up
their their messaging all around the
screen
if you can't actually see it it says r
values right and then
it's it shows the the black lives matter
fist twice
right the black lives matter fish shows
up twice in this particular
in this particular iteration of the
image the imagery that the dnc wants to
feature
okay so here is a dnc pastor literally
saying that america's gonna go to hell
if we don't open our borders
you had the nerve to build a wall while
at the same time you have in
the harbor there in new york a statue of
liberty
saying give me your tired your huddled
masses yearning to breathe free
jesus will say america if you don't get
your act together
you can you may well go to hell why
because in as much as you do it to the
least of these
my sisters and brothers you are also
doing it unto me
so open your borders or going to hell it
was a hell of a message they didn't
feature this one in prime time other
things that were not featured in prime
time so they had these
dnc panels one of the panelists led off
the panel they were going to play the
national anthem and he literally says
this is the dnc caucus and council
meeting the youth council right this for
the utes the utes okay so this panelist
says you know we're gonna play the
national anthem
at home in your basement if you're
watching this you can either rise
or you can kneel for the national anthem
solid look here for the dnc
many of the videos and pictures you're
about to see were recorded before covet
which is why the kids are not social
distancing however
the audio was recorded over the past
month you may rise or kneel
if you are able for your preference okay
so the heart and soul of the dnc is all
the stuff that happens not in prime time
i just like the heart and soul of what
you look like is the stuff you don't put
on your dating profile
okay then there's a panelist this is a
solid one there's a panel yesterday
about the green new deal and one of
these panelists just says
from her couch presumably in her
mother's house that the green new deal
should be utilized
to full-on destroy capitalism again
stuff that ain't going to be featured
this is the dnc caucus and council
meeting the youth council the youth
council is the future of the democratic
parties if you're wondering the future
of the democratic party it looks a lot
like aoc and not very much like joe
biden here is these panelists saying
it's time to destroy capitalism
this future that we all want that we're
all trying to build
um really is about the destruction of
colonization
white supremacy and capitalism
we must uh we must really move away from
these
systems and these frameworks if we
really want to
live in a future that does have a
regenerative economy
and um does enable liberation and equity
for our
communities ah kill capitalism and kill
colonization i'm not sure like who's
recolonizing the moon like what are we
talking about here so that's the solid
stuff happening again before prime time
gwen carr who's eric garner's mom
also appeared prior to prime time and
suggested we
can this may have actually been during
prime time and said we can't let things
settle down right we can't under no
circumstances can we let things settle
down
it seems like we might want to let
things settle down considering our
cities have been burning for months at
this point but here's eric garner's mom
i know when my son was murdered there
was a big
uprising but then it settled down
we can't let things settle down we
have to go to the politicians and we
have to hold their feet to the fire
because otherwise the big uprising is
not going to mean
a lot okay and and so there she was and
we can't let things settle down and joe
biden giving
randomly a fist and randomly very very
excited
finally in the pre-convention the
pre-prime time convention ayanna
pressley
the ringo starr of the squad she
actually praised
the quote-unquote protesters who were
rising up in portland you know the
people trying to burn down federal
buildings and throwing
fireworks at cops and stuff she was very
very happy with this here was diana
presley
right now we are managing against
converging public health and economic
crises
amid a national reckoning on racial
injustice in this country
communities from boston to portland and
everywhere in between
are rising up to demand accountability
and divestment from broken systems
okay good stuff right there she's
looking the rising up in portland
it's been great it's been great for the
country okay so now we finally get to
prime time so here is the positive phase
that the democrats
want to put out there and here's the
problem it's not just a face it is many
faces like lots of different faces the
democrats are all things to all people
except the only thing that unifies them
is the glue of orange man bad
trump is really bad the glue is not joe
biden right joe biden again is just that
stuffed animal in the corner and he's
just in the closet with e.t
joe biden but the real glue here is
orange man
bad and so this led to some kind of
awkward moments
the whole thing was very awkward and
kind of off-putting the only person who
really had a good night was michelle
obama
who is very good on camera everybody
else was pretty terrible on camera we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let us talk about keeping your home safe
and secure so when somebody arrives at
your door and knocks on your door
you may not be home and one of the ways
that robbers sometimes gain access to
your house they knock on the door make
sure you're not home
and then they break in well with ring
you are always at home ring has security
products for every corner of your home
inside and out
best of all you can see it all in one
simple app with ring you can keep an eye
on your home no matter where you are
right from your phone if someone stops
by or something's going on
ring lets you know it's peace of mind
any time and knowing that your home is
protected
whatever you call home ring has
everything you need to protect it see
and speak
to whomever is at your door from
anywhere with video doorbells keep an
eye on every corner of your house with
easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams i love ringing make sure
that i can keep an eye on my kids no
matter where i am
because when they are at home they're
frequently attempting to do physical
bodily harm to themselves and so i need
to keep an eye on my property just for
that alone
forget about the fact that i actually
care about security and want to know
what's going on
at my front gate got a special offer on
the ring welcome kit at ring.com it
comes with ring video doorbell 3 and
chime pro the perfect way to start your
ring experience
plus free two-day shipping go to
ring.com ben that is ring.com go check
them out right now
ring.com ben okay so as i say this whole
thing was very awkward because normally
a convention is where some of the party
business gets done
it basically is a giant party i mean i
went to the 2012 republican national
convention
in tampa and even that one was a giant
party it's a lot of fun
there are a lot of kind of hangouts that
are going on it's sort of like comic-con
for political nerds
essentially well the audience last night
looked absolutely bored the dnc made the
very odd decision to put cameras
in the houses of random dnc fans and
they looked like
alternatively they couldn't wait to get
up and go pee during the commercial
break that never came
or like they were going to absolutely
fall asleep
fall into a coma the footage the
cutaways to them
they they just look like okay are we on
camera right now i'm am i supposed to
like be
it's like you are during any sort of
zoom conference like any zoom conference
you just hope
that you don't make enough noise that
the camera automatically flashes to you
because you're actually in your
underwear
and scratching yourself in the nether
regions that that's what it looked like
over at the dnc
last night okay so time to contrast the
prime time
and the pre-prime time so as you'll
remember in the pre-prime time they
played the national anthem and told
people to kneel or rise
for the national anthem which is a hell
of a take at the actual dnc like the
prime time dnc
they played the national anthem very
very patriotic stuff nobody kneeling
at all it actually was quite a beautiful
rendition of the national anthem i
thought they had a bunch of people cut
together sort of a zoom version of the
national anthem it was quite nice
[Music]
i mean i i think not i mean you can like
you can pretend that you like patriotism
i guess if you're the democratic party
and when you're not openly celebrating
colin kaepernick kneeling for the
national anthem and suggesting that it's
the anthem of a cruel racist nation
biden's grandkids then emerge to lead
the pledge of allegiance
which again democrats have said is bad
because it includes the phrase under god
right so but but now it's good again
right again this is the dating profile
for the democrats we're not that crazy
we like the national anthem and the
pledge of allegiance and then sato voce
it's like well but if you kneel for the
national anthem that's the best of
america
and if you say the pledge of allegiance
is too weirdly religious
that's also the best of america so here
they were pretending they like the
pledge of allegiance not the kids i'm
sure the kids love the play i'm sure
that they all love the pledge of
allegiance here are the
united kids of america and into the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all now let me
just say if they play this at the rnc
the democrats get very very upset
because they said under god very very
bad okay then the democrats opened who
did they open with
they opened with famed woman of the
people eva longoria
from like desperate housewives who has
become a political figure in her own
right she was featured
at the last convention in 2016 that
super successful convention
she introduced this thing and then she
introduced regular people uh the regular
people
hollywood's bizarre fixation with the
democratic party and the democratic
party's bizarre fixation with hollywood
took on some really weird overtones in
this particular dnc as we'll see the way
the dnc concluded the evening
was probably the weirdest way that any
evening of a convention has ever been
concluded i mean it was super super odd
we'll get to that in a little bit here's
eva longoria opening this thing up
because
we all need to hear from the lady who
hasn't been relevant since desperate
housewives
the past few months have tested us all
we've lost more than a hundred and
seventy thousand family members and
friends to covid
this tragedy is compounded by the loss
of jobs and income
but it's not just the past few months
the past four years
have left us as a nation diminished and
divided
and yet in the middle of the fear and
sorrow
and the uncertainty people have come
together
because they know we are better than
this america
is better than this okay so this was the
message is more
more in sorrow than in anger we are
better than this america's better than
this
we are the uniters yes sure we've been
allowing people to run roughshod through
america's major cities and burn crap
sure we've been suggesting for literally
years at this point that the united
states is inherently quite evil
sure we have been promulgating bizarre
conspiracy theories about the 2016
election for five years four or five
years at this point
but we've been out here uniting america
we're super big into
uniting america it's what we are into
every day the uniting
of america so this is this was their
this was their message it was about
empathy
and unity and i know you're sitting to
yourself going wait a second empathy and
unity
like you haven't been haven't we been
watching people burning
cities to the ground and as for your
your unity
haven't we been watching you pretend
that southern states are evil
because they're not andrew cuomo and the
answer is yes all of that is real and
all of that has been happening but
that's not the dating profile guys the
dating profile is unity
unity so basically what the democrat
this democratic strategy last night was
donald trump as a mean man
it wasn't about his policies very little
was discussed about his policies and
there was very little focus put on
working men and women across the country
right there was very little about the
democrats economic plans how they're
going to make
life better for working people in the
united states which is usually something
they focus on the blue-collar workers
instead it was sort of like a bizarre
recap of 2016
where everything was culturally focused
and focused in on trump's character now
it didn't work in 2016.
maybe it'll work this time because
people are more upset about covet but
it's it's a weird strategy to take right
because
you could theoretically talk about the
competence level more than anything else
and this is what michelle obama did
right that's why she's the most
successful politician of any of these
clowns
but that really isn't what they went for
instead what they went for overall was
isn't the country just feeling too mean
right now and i'm looking at democrats
who have been
involved in canceling anything they
don't like and suggesting everybody they
don't like is a racist
and believing that america is filled to
the brim with bigots
and horrible people i'm just thinking
you guys are the expositors of american
unity
truly you want an overarching government
that crams down on 49
of the population the political
preferences of 51 of the population
you're looking forward to a federal
government overriding fundamental
american rights ranging from freedom of
association
it's a freedom of religion and you guys
are the unifiers and the empathetic ones
but that requires a little bit of
background knowledge so most people
don't have that background knowledge and
so what they see instead is
look at these nice people and they're
saying nice things there's so much
so much niceness so much niceness so it
was a made for hollywood version of
reality that included some bizarre
moments and the democrats featured
george floyd's brother
he asked for a moment of silence now
again not a person in america thinks
that george floyd should die
no one right not a republican not a
democrat nobody thinks george floyd
should be dead okay and as it turns out
the fact pattern may be
that he actually did not die of the knee
to the neck right the original state
autopsy suggested that he didn't die of
the need in the neck that he actually
died because he had
some pretty significant pre-existing
drug use and medical conditions
the democrats start with george floyd's
brother asking for a moment of silence
and talking about george floyd because
this is sort of a hollywood
production in the dnc the focus is not
on how we solve the problem of police
brutality instead
the focus is on on talking about george
floyd's character which is it's kind of
a weird focus because george floyd had a
very long criminal record
the story of george floyd that makes it
tragic is not actually
george floyd's criminality right i mean
what makes it tragic is that george
floyd shouldn't have died and now he's
dead
but instead what was put out there was
the legacy of george floyd as
as like a human being and if you're
going to talk about that then it's
almost impossible not to talk about the
fact that he did
he was arrested and did time in jail for
armed robbery in which he pointed a gun
at a pregnant woman right
that's not relevant to his actual death
but
because you're trying to create an
overall narrative
instead you sort of put out that message
which is which is a strange and kind of
factual message to the actual problem
which is police brutality which does
crop up so here was that message last
night
my brother george was selfless he always
made sacrifices for his family
friends and even complete strangers
george had a given spirit
a spirit that has shown up on streets
around our nation
and around the world please join me
in a moment of silence to honor george
and the many other souls we lost to hate
and injustice and when this moment ends
let's make sure we never stop saying
their names okay and the names that he's
talking about are of course the names of
people
who have died in altercations with
police he's not talking about as the
democratic party will never talk about
the names of black americans who are
killed in inner city violence which is
significantly more prevalent
than cops killing black americans under
disputed circumstances okay we're going
gonna get to more of this
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that
what you could really use these days is
a nice couch i mean everybody's watching
this stuff from zoom right i mean you're
doing
everything you can on zoom these days if
you've been listening to the show for a
while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix mattress so
exciting news helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door
so what makes an all form sofa really
cool well for starters it is the easiest
way you can customize the sofa using
premium materials
and at a fraction of the cost of
traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill
stain and scratch resistant the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
and shape to make sure it's perfect for
you
and your home they've got arm chairs and
love seats all the way up to an
eight-seat sectional so there's
something for everybody we've got one at
home it is just fantastic i have an
all-form sofa we picked out a three-seat
sofa with chase
in the sand color with espresso legs if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds a little risky you really
don't need to worry about it because you
get 100 days to decide if you want to
keep it
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free and give
you a full refund
they also have a forever warranty like
literally forever so it's durable it's
super comfortable it looks fantastic
and made just for you to find your
perfect sofa check out allforum.com
and all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
right now which is a great deal 20
off all orders when you go to
allform.com
that's all form dot com okay then we get
to the actual politicians
in the dnc and so we begin with the also
rounds meaning the people who were once
sort of considered for the vp slot and
then were completely ignored because
they didn't fit the bill so amy
klobuchar was allowed like 60 seconds to
talk about why she doesn't like trump
and again
that is the only message here right
there's no message about why biden is
good
it's all about how trump donald trump is
bad here was amy klobuchar passed over
because the democrats decided they
needed to check intersectional boxes
say heroes klopitar who won many more
votes than kamala harris but he's not
the vice presidential candidate
making a joke about trump hating the
post office or something
i believe that the right to vote is
fundamental
and the post office is essential
you know the president may hate the post
office
but he's still going to have to send
them a change of address card
come january
okay then there is gretchen whitmer the
the governor of michigan
who has presided over a pretty
significant death toll in the state of
michigan in fact if you look at state by
state in the united states
it's one of the worst hit states right
she she was one of the people who was
apparently shipping the old people
back to the nursing homes with covid
right that was one of the actual
policies
in the state of michigan michigan
currently ranks ninth in america in
terms of
death rate per million surpassed only by
new jersey new york massachusetts
connecticut louisiana rhode island
dc and mississippi okay so here she was
last night saying that joe biden and
kamala harris will lead by example
again the way the democrats mean lead by
example is we're not actually going to
do any
leading we're just going to have joe
biden say things sort of the same way
that joe biden says he wants a national
mass mandate
with no empowering authority and no
actual plan that's leading by example
the way gretchen whitmer
leads by example is by banning people
from buying seeds at the local store
while allowing her husband to go boating
or something
joe biden and kamal harris will lead by
example
it'll be science not politics or ego
that will drive their decisions they
know
the health of our people goes hand in
hand with the strength of our economy
they know action begets action
over the past few months we've learned
what's essential
rising to the challenge not denying it
um by rising to the challenge she means
that she did a terrible job in michigan
and people live in michigan no this is
the case then muriel bowser who's
briefly considered on the vp ticket
right the dc mayor who's most famous for
painting stuff on sidewalks while people
get shot in her city
she she emerged to talk about
her amazing record at the dnc
the story of our nation's capital is a
story of reckoning
it was here that john lewis and dr king
spoke on the steps of the lincoln
memorial
but we have to do something too each and
every one of us
challenge our own biases if we see
something
do something together we can turn this
reckoning into a re-imagining of a
nation
where we the people means all the people
and she shot this from directly above
her giant black lives matter mural
uh that is that is located in the middle
of the street in washington dc
it hasn't stopped people from getting
shot in washington dc but she at least
gets to talk about it finally the
democrats moved on to andrew cuomo okay
so their big picture
because again they don't have very good
policies in fact no policies
so far as i can see because the
democratic pitch is that donald trump is
a mean bad man who's mean and bad
they're focusing in on covid right covet
is the big thing this is the overarching
meta-narrative
is that donald trump doesn't care about
you and that is why your family member
died of covid
but you know who does care about you
andrew cuomo the worst governor in
america
so they trotted out andrew cuomo now i
don't know what kind of perverse sense
of humor you have to have to trot out
andrew cuomo
to talk about success and failure in
covet this is like trotting out the
captain of the titanic to talk about
avoiding icebergs
okay the headlines from new york these
days are astonishing it'll be things
like in the new york times like new york
handled the first wave will they handle
the second
if i handle the first wave mate everyone
died all of the humans died then sure
great job andrew cuomo but andrew cuomo
was trotted out at the dnc
and he made some um he made some weird
comments he
he suggested for example that covet was
mostly a metaphor
a metaphor that killed 33 000 people in
his state but
that's a hell of a metaphor it's a good
metaphor right there here is here's
new york governor andrew cuomo talking
about how covet is a symptom
not illness kovid just demonstrates how
we were already so divided
what coven mostly suggests is that you
probably shouldn't cover up nursing home
deaths
his state deliberately covered up
nursing home deaths said there were 6
600 of them there were 11
000. here is uh the governor of new york
andrew cuomo who when he is not being
grilled by his brother about his nostril
size is letting old people die in his
state
we went through hell but we have learned
much
we know that our problems go beyond the
covet virus covet is the symptom
not the illness our nation is in crisis
and in many ways covet is just a
metaphor
a virus attacks when the body is weak
and when it cannot defend itself
over these past few years america's body
politics has been weakened
in many ways it's not a metaphor and
like the ways where people
were suffocating to death it was not
such a metaphor
in a lot of ways it wasn't a metaphor
like when people were not allowed to see
their their loved ones as they
lay dying as their lungs basically
ceased to function it turned out
not such a good metaphor it was mostly
not a metaphor
according to andrew cuomo it's a
metaphor it's a metaphor for his
excellent leadership
and then he talked about divisions in
america andrew cuomo the guy who's right
now saying
i'm gonna ban people from other states
because new york handled this great but
everybody else handled it terribly
well he sits on by state the second
worth death permian rate
in america the only state that surpasses
is new jersey here's andrew cuomo
suggesting
that we've learned how bad things can
get when we're divided that's why we
have to
unite unite around my garbage policy
the temerity that it takes to trot out
andrew cuomo at your convention after he
has presided over the greatest
natural loss of life in the united by
natural i mean illness related loss of
life
in the united states in decades is
astonishing i mean the gall
is just incredible here is andrew cuomo
today we trail the world in defeating
covet we have over five million cases
americans learned a critical lesson how
vulnerable we are when we are divided
and how many lives can be lost when our
government is incompetent
but we learned something else my friends
we saw the negative but we also saw the
positive
as they proved their way failed we
proved that our way
succeeded uh
which way would be that would that be
like um what no
andrew cuomo being trotted out as a
success story is one of the most
extraordinary examples of gaslighting i
think i've ever seen in my entire life
that is an incredible incredible thing
it's like o.j simpson talking about how
to prevent murder
my god people wow wow wow
by the way if you want to talk about
shamelessness wait until we get to
the next person that the democrats had
speak they had a woman from arizona
whose father died of kovid speak at the
convention and say
maybe the most shameless thing i've ever
heard on a democratic national
convention stage her name was kristen
arkisa
literally her entire billing is father
out of coronavirus
that's that's the only reason that she
is here right is because she's a
democrat and her dad died of coronavirus
and she blames trump for this this is
one of the most shameless things i have
ever seen at a political convention it
is truly shameless
okay i feel awful for the lady because
anybody who has a relative died that's a
horrible horrible experience
but this is a shameless political move
by the democrats to bring out a woman
whose parent died of kovid to blame
trump and do it in the way that she does
is on a political and immoral level
despicable i mean really despicable
listen to what she says it's it's
patently crazy
here here we go my dad
mark anthony or kisa should be here
today
but he isn't he had faith in donald
trump
he voted for him listened to him
believed him and his mouthpieces when
they said that coronavirus was under
control
and going to disappear that it was okay
to end social distancing rules before it
was safe
that if you had no underlying health
conditions you'd probably be fine
my dad was a healthy 65 year old
his only pre-existing condition was
trusting donald trump
and for that he paid with his life
so apparently only trump voters have
died anybody who listens to trump died
if you didn't listen to trump you're
fine
all those people in new york are
entirely republicans to blame trump
for this guy dying of covid i mean this
is equivalent to when
when there was an ad in 2012 blaming
mitt romney and bain capital
for firing a guy so his wife would later
die of cancer like
the the idea that like is there any
evidence that he
just went out there willy-nilly and
started macking on on people who had
coveted
because he believed trump that's such an
unbelievable statement
that that her dad is dead because he
trusted trump as opposed to what like
you know what this is honestly it that
sort of of take
on life is a bizarrely ritualistic take
on what
it takes to mitigate risk that if you
just don't vote for trump i guess you're
immune to covet now if you don't believe
trump
and you pay no attention to trump then
apparently you're immune from covet
which is weird because
every single state that leads in death
in the united states is a blue state
every single one all of them the only
one in the top ten
in terms of death per millions that is
not a blue state is mississippi
every other one is a blue state so i i'm
failing to see the connection between
you believe donald trump and you die of
govid
that that that's an absurd contention
truly absurd but the democrats trotted
that out in prime time last night
okay in a second we're going to get to
the actual political part of the
convention
and this was really three separate
speakers
who were featured in the political part
of the convention and they gave very
conflicting messages
one was john kasich oh god no please god
no not john kasich
bernie sanders he shows up again he's
back
and michelle obama the greatest wisest
and most wonderful
of all human beings we'll get to all of
that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that you're spending
an awful lot of time these days with
blue light
technologies meaning anything with the
screen so are your kids you can give you
headaches it can make you not sleep as
well
at night it can give you eye strain
literally any amount of excessive screen
time with the digital device
creates eye strain common symptoms from
too much
blue light headaches blurry vision dry
tired eyes trouble sleeping
why don't you get some felix gray
glasses they're fantastic they filter up
to 90
of all blue light and 15 times more
where it matters most
using an industry-leading lens
technology proprietary to felix gray
nine and ten felix gray customers report
significant symptom relief
felix gray features highly curated
timeless styles made from italian
acetate makes them stylish durable
lightweight and really comfortable
trust your eyes to the most trusted
brand in blue light over 250 000 happy
customers
order online free shipping free returns
free exchanges always all orders include
a custom hard case and lens cloth i've
got my felix grays they look great they
reduce my eyestrain because again i
spend a lot of time on screens
if you're getting your kids ready for
back to school you can shop felix gray
blue light glasses for kids from august
24th august 30th for 15
off kids glasses the offer apply only to
kids glasses go to felix gray
glasses.com for the absolute best
quality blue light filtering glasses
on the market again they have
proprietary technology it makes them
better than anything else on the market
check out felix grayglasses.com felix
dot com grayglasses.com bands do what i
did start taking care of your eyes feel
better
work smarter free shipping for your
turns free exchanges always felix
grayglasses.com okay we're gonna get to
the heavily political arena of the
convention
the the kasich sanders and michelle
obama triumvirate
first got to tell you about exclusive
membership over at the daily wire all
access all access members get to join
all access live that is our exclusive
live stream discussions hosted every
night by each of the hosts including
me this thursday august 20th we'll be
doing a very special live stream
watch party covering the dnc's biggest
speakers with the daily wires own matt
walsh the stream starts at 8 45 pm
eastern 5 45 pm pacific don't miss this
big opportunity to tune in and mock i
mean
mock watch the final night of the dnc
with matt walsh who's low-key brand of
humor
i feel might be a little biting all
access membership also features
exclusive access to live online
discussions with host writers special
guests
along with not one but two leftist tears
tumblers with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products so
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 20 off all access with
coupon code
access that's dailywire.com shapiro with
coupon code access to get 20
off your membership also this friday
we're doing a backstage if you've never
seen one of these you really should
check it out i get together with all the
other hosts here at daily wire it's a
lot of fun
for them they smoke cigars i eat an
unreasonable amount of popcorn
i get really really cynical and nasty
this friday 4 p.m pacific
go check it out you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so as i've been saying there are
variegated pitches for the democrats
last night pitch number one was
trump botched kovid let us show you this
great leader andrew cuomo
not the world's best pitch pitch number
two was we're super patriotic except
when we're telling people to kneel for
the national anthem
and then they trotted out pitch number
three which is here are our token
republicans
here they are they're here to yell about
how much they don't like donald trump
so they brought out john kasich oh yes
oh god
no please god no not john kasich
the former governor of ohio now governor
kasich
for some odd reason decided to do his
speech from an actual crossroads in case
you didn't get the metaphor were at a
crossroads gang
so he literally stood at a crossroads in
the middle of a field
like the scarecrow in wizard of oz
because he has no brain
and on one side of the crossroads was
quit the 2016 presidential race in march
to give ted cruz a shot at defeating
donald trump
thousands of crossroads he didn't take
he took the other one that said stay in
the race long enough to guarantee trump
the nomination
and then speak four years later at the
dnc and make an ass of yourself that was
the crossroads he chose but
he spoke about being at the crossroads
while literally standing at a crossroads
in case you didn't get the metaphor like
tom hanks at the end of castaway
here was john kasich a raisin in the sun
sometimes elections represent a real
choice a choice we make as individuals
and as a nation about which path we want
to take when we've come to challenging
times
america is at that crossroads today i'm
a lifelong republican
but that attachment holds second place
to my responsibility to my country
that's why i've chosen to appear at this
convention
in normal times something like this
would probably never happen
but these are not normal times no i feel
like basically anywhere there's a
spotlight you can find john kasich my
favorite john kasich clip
was back during the 2016 campaign my
favorite was when he went into a section
of williamsburg in brooklyn campaigning
and he started lecturing orthodox jews
on on what it says in the bible
did you know it's what it says in the
book like nope they kind of do
actually it turns out john kasich that
dude is the worst he's the worst
so i'm glad that you democrats have him
welcome to the party
i i hope you enjoy this gift that we
gave you and john kasich
okay so the juxtaposition of john kasich
with bernie sanders is pretty
astonishing it was pretty astonishing
because
kasich at the in the middle of his
speech he's talking about the wonders of
joe biden dead man standing over here
here is my late departed joe biden
and he says don't worry you know i'm a
republican you think that i would vote
for somebody who's going to go radical
i'd never vote for anybody who's gonna
go radical joe biden isn't gonna go
radical i mean look the man's dead he
can't go radical here is
john kasich a man who again mostly
resembles a crumbled up piece of paper
in your pocket or a seat from the local
restaurant that went through the washing
machine in your jeans
here's john kasich about how
joe biden won't go radical because he's
not alive anymore
i'm sure there are republicans and
independents who couldn't imagine
crossing over to support a democrat
they fear joe may turn sharp left and
leave them behind
i don't believe that because i know the
measure of the man
is reasonable faithful respectful
and you know no one pushes joe around
um he's reasonable he's fine no one
pushes him around no one
pushes him around quick cut to bernie
sanders bernie sanders speaks to the
convention last night
he's like by the way you know who now
runs this party it's me
me your communist fight man i'm back and
i'm gonna tell you how
john kasich was saying that your biden
won't be pushed around
well let me explain to you that i push
him around all the time
in fact i actually have joe on a gurney
in the back
just for fun i push him around side to
side back and forth it's really fun
in fact my ideas are now the mainstream
remember when they used to pretend that
i was not a mainstream politician
now i've basically taken them over like
the facehugger an alien
i went on joe biden's face and then i
went down into his body
and i burst forth in full socialist
flowering
bernie sanders explaining that not only
will he push joe biden around but he is
joe biden now
he just wears a joe biden mask like the
guy from silence of the lambs
here we go bernie sanders
our campaign ended several months ago
but our movement continues and is
getting
stronger every day many of the ideas we
fought for
that just a few years ago were
considered radical
are now mainstream so is that a bit of a
conflicting message john kasich's like
they won't go radical guys they won't go
radical and i can assure you they won't
go radical because i know joe biden and
joe biden is not alive
and then bernie's like i can assure you
we definitely have gone radical and uh
you're gonna have to get over it
i believe bernie because tom perez said
before the convention that bernie wrote
the convention
and wrote wrote the wrote the platform
and then bernie sanders
uh jumped into the main message of the
evening because again all of this is all
over the place right
biden is a moderate but he's also a
radical biden
is very patriotic but also kneeling for
the anthem is very
patriotic america is a wonderful
patriotic place filled with great people
but also america's systemically racist
but there's one unifying message and
that is donald trump is not normal so
here is bernie sanders saying donald
trump is not normal he is orange and
looks like orange and also is bad like
an orange from the godfather whenever
you see an orange somebody's gonna get
shot donald trump is like orange for the
american people
during this president's term the
unthinkable
has become normal he has tried to
prevent people from voting
undermined the u.s postal service
deployed the military and federal
agents against peaceful protesters
threatened to delay the election and
suggested
that he will not leave office if he
loses
this is not normal and we must never
treat it
like it is tell me more about normality
communist who has praised every evil
regime from cuba to china to
the soviet union tell me more bernie
about not normal
about not normal bernie sanders okay
then finally the democrats got to the
most beloved person in america i mean by
poll numbers this is true
michelle obama who as we say has
undergone a complete reinvention twice
so first there was michelle obama
radical life partner to barack obama
then there was michelle obama
wonderful apolitical first lady beloved
of all americans
and now there's michelle obama political
figure and she's back
so michelle obama speaks last night now
again it's weird
for the first lady the last first lady
to speak at a convention
that doesn't involve her husband really
like i don't i believe laura bush
did not speak certainly not in prime
time at the 2008 convention
for for john mccain um but michelle
obama is a political figure
one of the things that is so perverse
about the obamas generally
is the is the high level lying i mean
they're really good at it really good at
it so some people are just bad liars
like kamala harris is a terrible liar
she happens to be an awful liar every
time she lies she breaks into the joker
laugh
as i always tell my children when we
watch animated films the way that you
can tell the bad guy is the bad guy
always laughs a lot
bad guys always seem to be having the
most fun in the movies it doesn't matter
what movie you watch like
it could be a marvel movie it could be a
it could be a cartoon movie
whenever you have somebody who laughs
like a crazy person that's the bad guy
because bad guys have all the fun kamala
harris laughs that's
her tell the crazy joker laugh every
time she lies
not the obamas the obamas are really
smooth so they've been able to portray
themselves as above the fray
and really nice people who get along
with not partisan knife fighters in any
way which of course is utterly untrue
barack obama was one of the most vicious
partisan knife fighters in my political
lifetime it's amazing
amazing that he was able to come off as
empathetic i mean the guy's really
gifted that way
michelle turns out to be a fairly
radical character herself
again a lady who in 2008 openly said the
only reason that she'd been proud of her
country in her adult lifetime was the
nomination of her husband which is an
amazing statement i've been proud of
this country when barack obama was
president i've been proud of this
country when donald trump was president
i've been proud of this country when
bill clinton and george w bush were
president
my pride in the united states of america
is not reliant on who has been nominated
for presidents of the united states
doesn't mean i like everybody who's been
president
doesn't mean i like any of the nominees
but my pride in the country goes a
little deeper than that michelle obama
has always been fairly radical she's
always been really political
very very political but last night she
had to portray herself as an apolitical
figure and the media
doing their best to to prop her up on
this one she began her speech by saying
she hates politics which is just
laughable
michelle obama hating politics sure i'm
sure michelle obama despises politics
by which she means that she absolutely
adores politics has been in it nearly
her entire life
you know that i tell you exactly what
i'm feeling
you know i hate politics but you also
know that i
care about this nation you know how much
i care about all of our children
okay so i find this stuff kind of
off-putting i mean shockingly i'm not
captain empathy
but this is the democrat pitch in the
end the democratic pitch is going to be
donald trump doesn't care about people
like you which is the biggest question
in any presidential election
usually it's does this person care about
people like you trump did that he
actually
won that argument over hillary who
appeared to be completely non-caring
about people who are not like her
michelle obama makes the case that trump
is not captain caring
which is obviously true right and that
she is very careful it all comes down to
empathy now
as i've mentioned before there are
entire books written
about the problems with empathy in
american politics there's an entire book
by a guy named paul bloom who's a social
scientist
called against empathy the case for
rational compassion right there's a
difference
between having compassion for somebody
on a rational level and empathy
that forces you to abandon your kind of
concerns about people who are not the
person with whom you are empathizing
but democrats have decided that
elections ought to be referenda on
empathy
which always is going to cut in favor of
the the democrats because for democrats
empathy means us doing something for you
no matter how bad it is no matter
whether it's counterproductive
and democrats can always say we'll spend
more money well empathy can be equated
with money in this particular iteration
so
their case is donald trump is not
empathetic we however are empathetic
we are classy we take the high road so
here is michelle obama saying the
democrats take the high road which um
is weird because i've been alive so no
you don't
no you don't i'm old enough to remember
when joe biden your current presidential
nominee said that mitt romney was going
to put
black people back in slavery he was
going to put them back in chains
i'm old enough to remember when the
obama campaign ran with the line that
mitt romney was a sexist
because he had a binder of women he was
examining for a vp candidate sort of
like hmm
joe biden having a binder full of women
he was examining is examining for his vp
candidate i'm old enough to remember
when barack obama threatened the banks
by saying the pitchforks are out front
and i can just let them come get you
but according to michelle obama they
always take the high road which is just
the greatest myth in american politics
over the past four years a lot of people
have asked me
when others are going so low does going
high
still really work my answer
going high is the only thing that works
because when we go low when we use
those same tactics of degrading and
dehumanizing others
we just become part of the ugly noise
that's drowning out everything else
she's really good at this right she's
doing without an audience she
understands that it has to be like an
oprah direct to camera moment
she's very like just on an aesthetic
level you have to acknowledge that she
is very good at her job
right here that doesn't mean that she's
telling the truth because as it turns
out when it comes to degrading and
dehumanizing and mischaracterizing your
opposition
and not taking the high road michelle
obama did plenty of that last night most
obvious example she suggested that the
trump administration
throws people in cages okay so here she
was last night suggesting the trump
administration throws people in cages
they see our leaders labeling fellow
citizens
enemies of the state while emboldening
torture-bearing white supremacists
they watch in horror as children are
torn from their families and
thrown into cages and pepper spray and
rubber bullets
are used on peaceful protesters for
photo op
sadly this is the america that is on
display for the next generation
weird because of the america that was on
display for during your administration
was complete
utter chaos in ferguson missouri
complete utter chaos in washington dc
and baltimore
so um yeah also i seem to remember that
you know where those cages got started
you know where they got started those
horrible horrible cages um with with
barack obama i have some bad news from
the obama administration era
uh those cages began with forced
separation policy
promulgated by the ninth circuit court
of appeals they began under the obama
administration which led to that famous
botch where the media started putting
out a photo of kids in cages that
actually was from
the obama time but don't worry she take
she took the high road right there
and the the trump administration is only
using rubber bullets and tear gas
against peaceful protesters there are no
actual rioters in the streets they don't
exist they're gone but she's taking the
high road guys
very very high very very high road also
she says that the white house doesn't
care about black people which is also
taking the high road so she says that
there's a never-ending list of black
people who've been murdered by the
police a never-ending list of black
people murdered by the police
um well actually according to the
washington post they're a grand total of
15 black people who are killed unarmed
by the cops last year
15 so that seems like an ending list not
never-ending it seems like mostly an
ending list
and in the vast majority of those cases
the people who are quote-unquote unarmed
actually were either going for a cop's
gun or using some other type of weapon
to attack the cop
or we're physically in an altercation
with a gop but apparently it's a
never-ending list and the white house
won't say black lives matter
the white house won't say black lives
matter because they don't want to mimic
the rhetoric of the actual black lives
matter movement because the phrase black
lives matter is a semantic trap that has
been laid by democrats it is a
semantically overloaded term
right that is why the white house has
not used the term black lives matter
because it is unclear what it means i've
mentioned this
several times it means one the utterly
unobjectionable idea that black lives
matter just as much as any other lives
in the united states
to the perfectly objectionable idea that
the united states is systemically racist
and that people are targeting black
people for death which is utterly untrue
the vast majority of black people who
are killed in the united states are
killed by other black people just like
the vast majority of white people in the
united states who are killed
are killed by other white people okay so
that's a completely arguable idea and
then finally there's the completely
inarguable idea that you should not be
endorsing the black lives matter
organization
a radical awful terrible group okay but
she says that there's a never-ending
list again this is michelle obama who is
just the greatest wisest
mom mom is disappointed in us that was
the method that was sort of the the
message of this
because she's everybody's mom michelle
obama that tells she's portrayed by the
media mom is disappointed in you
and she's disappointed in you because
the white house won't say that black
lives matter while endless
numbers of black people are being
murdered apparently by the system
which isn't true but she's gonna push
that line anyway
as george floyd brianna taylor
and a never ending list of innocent
people of color
continue to be murdered stating the
simple fact that a black life matters
is still met with derision from the
nation's highest
office never ending list guys because
whenever we look to this white house for
some leadership
or consolation or any semblance of
steadiness
what we get instead is chaos division
and a total and utter lack of empathy
okay then again it's going to come back
time and time again to empathy and we're
going to blink very slowly for the
camera
lack of empathy and caring right that's
the shtick that's the shtick
is that trump should care now she's
never going to mention the fact that
there are full-on riots in major
american cities
that have taken more lives by the way
than the police took of unarmed black
americans last year
she's not going to mention any of that
she's not going to mention the complete
the complete looting of entire districts
of new york l.a
washington dc chicago you're not going
to mention any of that stuff because it
doesn't exist poof
it's just the trump isn't empathetic
that's the big problem here trump lacks
in empathy
and it doesn't matter that politician is
pushing the lying narrative that america
is systemically racist and targeting
black people for death in endless
numbers right there's a never-ending
list of black people targeted for death
by the cops
that is significantly more damaging to
america by the way what she says that
there's a never-ending list of black
americans being targeted by the cops
is significantly more of a lie and more
damaging to the united states than
donald trump
not saying the phrase black lives matter
because it's semantically overloaded but
she is going to pretend that this is all
just an issue of empathy and this is the
game the democrats love to play
if you disagree with them it's because
you're just not caring enough guys it's
cause you don't care and watch i will
show you how much i care because i'm
gonna blink slowly right now you ready
one two three go
caring did you see it did you see the
carrying happening right there that
means that i know what's best for
america
because i have empathy right that is
that is the shtick
okay and then michelle's and then
michelle actually lectured all americans
that we lack empathy
i mean she doesn't lack empathy but you
lack empathy here is michelle obama
again on empathy empathy empathy empathy
empathy
right now kids in this country are
seeing what happens when we
stop requiring empathy of one another
they're looking around wondering if
we've been lying to them this whole time
about who we are and what we truly value
they see people shouting in grocery
stores unwilling to wear a mask
to keep us all safe they see
people calling the police on folks
minding their own business
just because of the color of their skin
um if we're going to go with like
examples of lack of empathy in the
united states
i would probably those can fit the bill
sure i mean people not wearing masks
when they should be wearing masks and
screaming about it or
or people who are or people who are
calling the police on people
under unjust circumstances although
frankly i think that that is
is typically less of a statistical
problem but if i were going to go with
like lack of empathy in america today
i'd probably go with the people who are
literally stopping cars and then beating
the living hell out of people
because of their race that seems like
that might be a good one how about like
burning down stores
that's a good example of lack of empathy
notice what doesn't make the speech
of course because the fact is that not a
single democrat will condemn antifa will
condemn black lives matter looters and
rioters
not a single one but they are the party
of empathy so much empathy
incredible levels of empathy in fact and
by the way michelle obama
so much going high here so much going
high in the speech so for example
like michelle obama simply says that
without any evidence we're going to stop
black people from voting if you're the
trump administration
that america is stopping black people
from voting this is her going high guys
she's not undermining electoral
integrity only trump does that here she
was going high by saying that black
people are going to be stopped from
voting
right now folks who know they cannot win
fair and square
at the ballot box are doing everything
they can to stop us from voting
they're closing down polling places in
minority neighborhoods
they're purging voter rolls they're
sending people
out to intimidate voters and they're
lying
about the security of our ballots
these tactics are not new
okay and then she goes on to try and
compare this to the past of voter
suppression in the united states which
is patently crazy
again black americans have voted in
larger numbers than the percentage of
the population for several election
cycles in a row in the united states
actually barack obama was reelected in
almost solely because of that
statistically speaking and then finally
michelle gets to her final pitch which
is trump is in over his head which i
need to hear from a former first lady
who has run precisely zero things
zero like listen i may agree that trump
has botched a fair number of things
but michelle obama's experience with
running things is basically relegated to
the white house vegetable garden
hey if you wanna you wanna have barack
obama say this he's allowed to do it if
you want to have any governor say this
they're allowed
except for andrew cuomo he's not allowed
to say it but michelle obama's saying
that trump is in over his head
again i don't know what her
qualifications are to say this i
understand she's a popular political
figure and it's a popular thing to say
but i'm just wondering what she has run
so successfully that gives her the
credibility to say this sort of thing
donald trump is the wrong president for
our country
he has had more than enough time to
prove that he can do the job but he
is clearly in over his head he cannot
meet this moment
he simply cannot be who we need him to
be
for us it is what it is
it is what it is of course her
suggesting that trump doesn't care about
covet deaths because he said at one
point that when people die that is what
it is that doesn't change
and so a fully dishonest pretty vicious
viciously political partisan speech by
michelle obama effective
she's good at what she does i mean i'll
say that for her she's good at what she
does
but is she really above politics does
she hate politics you get that sense
from her
now that is the next level of the
democratic party so whatever happens
with joe biden recognize michelle
obama's on the horizon
and so the democrats concluded the dnc
last night
with uh perhaps the greatest sign yet of
their disconnect from many members of
the american public
they finished with billy porter who's
mostly famous
for dressing in women's clothing and
going to
large events and then getting the plot
to the media for like he
wears like full-on glittery dresses to
media events because he's an lgbt
activist and
i don't know what one has to do with the
other but i guess that's like a thing so
he he likes to wear glittery sequin
gowns to major events
uh and women's clothing and then he
receives widespread media praise
for this because somehow this is an
issue of activism the democrats
concluded the dnc last night
with billy porter playing a buffalo
springfield song in a bizarre cable
like late night cable access direct
access cable
take on a 1960s protest song by the way
this protest song
was uh written originally about the 1966
sunset strip
club riots what were those about for
those who don't know any uh
la history they're about a group of
teenagers and young people who wanted to
stay out past curfew and the neighbors
were like you're making too much noise
so they rioted
and so this has become a pro because the
60s were in many ways an incredibly
stupid time
like a couple of good things happen very
good things happen during the 60s the
civil rights act for example and then a
lot of really stupid crap happened
during the 60s including some pretty bad
music here was billy porter doing his
rendition of a buffalo springfield song
because this is what
in you wanna like everything they say
this is actually what the democratic
party is it's billy porter singing
buffalo springfield from 1966. children
what's that sound
everybody look what's going down
okay and then it's just a bunch of uh
slogans popping up behind black lives
matter the the black lives matter fist
uh him dancing strangely and wearing
like weird tape
maybe donald trump will be president
forever after all like forever
alrighty guys we'll be back here later
today with two additional hours of
content also
i'm doing an all-access live tonight so
we can discuss all of this otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton